with just hours to go until Thanksgiving
the woke left is going to all out to
make sure you are ashamed of America
this holiday season here now with more a
senior fellow at the Hoover institution
Victor Davis Hanson it seems sir like
they want uh they want Thanksgiving to
be canceled or at least forgotten to not
be as popular as Halloween let's say
what's going on out there
well I think it's part of a larger
Progressive leftist socialist agenda
that they want to control our futures
and they want to pose a suppressed
oppressed victimized and they can't find
enough culprits in the present so they
go back to the past they topple statues
they change names and they construct
Thanksgiving as this This Racist uh
holiday that it haunts them today but
when you actually look at Thanksgiving
it was a very tragic uh
voyage across to the new world and they
after one year or half of the pilgrims
had died and they were starving almost
and they finally had a harvest that they
could survive one more year and it was a
Thanksgiving and it was ecumenical and
it's been part of our traditions in one
way or another for you know over a
century and the idea that this is
somehow politicized or weaponizes once
again it's just a tool that they use to
find oppression where it doesn't exist
in the present so they go back to the
past and yeah hope that therefore they
can affect the country we've got a hard
break that is an excellent reminder sir
Happy Thanksgiving hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else